to the rainbow the [__] stories are
tremendous he I saw I we I did an
interview with him on that show and we
both had a few drinks told me his chick
kicked him out that night and was like
uh yeah it's bad I got to go to Europe
right now to do this thing with the
snake pit which was his band and so they
said so the PE his people say listen
we're here to promote snake pit album
whatever you do do not bring up guns in
roses do not bring up guns and roses and
in my head I'm by the way I've been
drinking with the guy so I'm not [__]
I'm not intimidated by the interview at
all and we've kind of already talked
about it a little bit he's brought
things up about it so we get in the
interview and my first thing is I got to
mention I got to ask you what happened
to guns and& roses this no one and
everyone's like what the [__] he just
real cool he goes man I'll tell you
what everyone it's really easy to be
friends with someone when you're broke
but people change when they become
millionaires he said and we just
realized we weren't going to be friends
we weren't the same kind of millionaires
he's like Axel wanted to buy property
and own rights to songs and and buy
mansions and live out in Malibu and I
wanted to buy poisonous snakes he was
like you know we're just very different
people and he's like that's all he's
like you know we toured so much that
when we finally got a break and we got
our money and we're like all right he
goes we had a moment to decide what kind
of I'm by the way I'm totally
paraphrasing and saying it the way I
remember it but he was like we had we
realized like all right now I get to
decide what kind of millionaire I am and
he's like for me I just moved right up
the hill from where we used to hang out
in a little nicer Place filled it with
poisonous snakes and [__] and and and
and guitars and just kept partying and
he's actual wanted to do [__] yoga
and go out to Malibu and do his own
private part like it it was like just
different people I was like that's
[__] fascinating because you do see
that you know like coming up in this
business there's guys that you're
friends with when you're young because
you're both trying to do open mics like
Demetri Martin and I were like really
good friends cuz we're both doing open
mics and not I'm not saying like either
of us are to blame for either of this
other other than just being very
different people and but when you're
hungry we're the same person we want to
get on stage but then when finally we're
getting a little stage time and and
we're starting to succeed we just go in
different directions CU we're not we our
wants are are different you know like he
got married and and then wanted to do
like alternative clubs and I was like I
want to hang out in the village and be
around noron and Bobby Kelly and P
Corelli and atel and heberg everyone
working there so it it's like it it's
interesting you know I kind of I wonder
if that I wonder if that continues to
happen in life I mean I don't know how
many [__] friends I've had as an
adult that you know you have kids with
and then you're all in the mommy and me
class and those your best friends and
then you guys go to a preschool and you
get brand new best friends and then you
go to a grade school you get brand new
best friends then you go to a middle
school you get brand new it's like
[__] life changes the only friends I
have that are constant are Comics it's
it's you know it I don't know where I'm
taking this I had a weird experience I
hung out with a friend that I haven't
seen for a year and we used to be like
really good friends and we're still
friends but like I've just been around
certain people for the past couple years
and then we we we got in the car and
they were like they were legit having a
conversation about the Kardashians about
the show like it
mattered and I couldn't I couldn't even
I like there were adult people who had
like jobs and bills and I was like I
just couldn't believe it you're in a bad
situation you're in a bad situation I
say the same to um to uh Jamie who works
with Joe and Redban who works with Joe
because you get to hang out with some of
you get to hang out as a fly on thewall
and a participant to some of the most
interesting [__] conversations that
people are having today I'm not saying
that me and Joey are doing it today but
like some of the people I've listened to
the interviews like the one you did with
uh with with uh not what's his name is
uh what's the guy his little brother his
uh [__] he was in he was in the movie
with you the longest Shard ni saturo
nuro I love that [__] I love that I
love that interview I listen to that
[__] beginning to end and I listened
to it a couple times because it was so
cool how him and his brother still love
each other and say they love each other
when they talk to each other on the
phone and I was like and but that's so
then when you try to hang out with like
like regular people they're never going
to be able to keep up to the
conversations you get to hear on a daily
basis well there's that but I I've hung
out with people who I used to work with
out here since then it's fine the iy can
hang out with people but it was just
like I I had never I hadn't experienced
that I and and I called Joey on the way
home I called you on the way home I was
just like it's weird you're like I've
been trying to tell you it's it's
uh when I got the longest yard I did a I
did a bar in that time they were trying
to open up a new comedy club in Jersey
City called The Rascals and they were
failing miserably it was just a horrible
location everything about it was
horrible I was was in shock for Rascals
do you remember the old Rascals I mean
Jesus Christ never no oh my God I
thought since you knew Jay and [__] like
that and I remember friends of mine came
and I was at the bar and I was very
cordial and I took pictures with all my
childhood friends I put in the paper I
contacted and 30 or 40 of them showed up
and like eight of them really scared the
[__] out of
me like they scared the [__] out of me
because I could just imagine imine like
I never really gave a [__] when I was a
kid the only guy that made me come in my
shorts was Julius Irving if you weren't
going to show up with Julius Irving
Charles Brun and the Clint would save it
you know what I'm saying then I liked
music I really got into music but still
I was never one of those guys I would
never take a picture i' never ask like I
saw Rich gear from here to 10 feet from
me and I had no right after office in
the gentleman he was 10t from me at
Studio 54 I didn't say one of those
clubs well not Studio stud but the the
rooftop or something he was 10 ft from
me I didn't say a [__] word I just
went back and told my friends that was
Richard [__] gear but there people I
have a friend a dear friend her brother
and I grew up she used to call me and
ask me if I knew you know people and it
was creepy after a while I had to stop
taking the calls yeah you know do I know
Courtney Kardashian I think she asked me
one time that was one of the last times
I take a call from her what do you say
yeah we hang out all the
time you try to be nice the phone rings
you pick it up you try to be nice and
all of a sudden you take it into this
direction well we me and my me and my
friend went to New York because we heard
she was going to be there at the Mud
Club so we I'm I'm just making this up
but you know this is the call I got from
her like three or four times and I'm
like you're a [__] adult and then
she's like can I call Ice Cube for her
because she lived in Jersey so Ice Cube
lives in North Bergen with his wife Coco
God so she wanted me to get Ice Cube's
number to her ice te or what's I te I
ice te's number I mean this was the [__]
I was getting you know me Lee the first
two calls I was okay with it and I
giggled and laughed like okay and one
day I was like get not [__] serious
are you yeah I want to ask them I want
to ask him questions about LA and Order
SVU Is that real and I was like listen
you got to get it together I called I
called my friend who gave me the number
who gave him my number and I [__]
went off on him like him and I do not
talk anymore because of that you cannot
give your number out to
somebody to ask you those type of
questions yeah he goes well she called
me and talked about a benefit I go
that's fine give me her number and I'll
call those people you never give out my
number yeah you know she you know and
listen there's nothing worse than
somebody calling you out of line there's
nothing worse when somebody calls you
out of line for somebody else hi this is
Josephine from whatever do you know how
how to get a hold of Berke Cher I want
to book him for an event really I'm on
the 405 in bumper to bumper traffic and
you got the call to call me for some
other Comics number I I had okay not
even to harass me yeah I can see you
harassing me showing up with a short
envelope on New Year's and trying to get
me to do some crazy gig but for you to
call me in bumper to bumper traffic on
the 405 listen the other day we just
finished doing a [__] murderous
workout at the gym kettle bells not only
did I swing the [__] medium one I
took the gorilla and swung that two
times yeah my body was in shock Lee and
I had done Jiu-Jitsu Sunday and
Monday and then we went to this
kettlebell class before the class
started I looked at Lee and I go Lee why
are we here you and I killed our joking
you and I killed ourselves I listen guy
we rolled around Lee how many times did
I say one more time oh like like 20
times one more time Lee three minutes
let's just do two minutes Lee wrestle
with him two minutes I'll take a
breather cuz there's a young kid Spencer
get in there with Lee and then take two
minutes you're the young one get the
[__] work us out you know then we went
back Monday did it all again Tuesday I'm
looking before the class started I
looked at I go Le why are we here Lee
thought I was [__] with him I go I'm
serious I can't walk we go into this
class we start doing all types of swings
then at the end he closes up with uh
three cleans and you got to walk across
the floor and then put the thing down
and do three more cleans it's a great
workout I'm not complaining about the
workout I'm just trying to stay in my
State of Mind by that point listen the
class starts at 11:00 short by
11:25 your mind is already throwing the
food at you that you're going to eat
because it's what's keeping you in that
class every time he goes this time we're
going to do 10 swings you looking I'm
going no we're
not we're just going to do two swings
and I'm tapping out I'm taking my wife
I'm going to eat a steak this is what in
the back because every time you do a set
of swings the first thing you think
about is a 9 in CU all I'm thinking
about in class is a 9 in 9 o the prime
rib lunch from uh Morton Morton bird ma
it's 219 five it's like six meals they
give you a chopped salad an 8 oz uh
filet with mashed potatoes they give you
a [__] dessert a chocolate mousse or
a cheesecake you can't go wrong for
$21.95 even if you're a deaf mute you go
in there and you drink water and you
leave a tip you can't go wrong you show
there with the small 27 a couple dimes
nobody's feelings get hurt you know what
I'm saying I mean the chop saddle alone
will fill you up yeah okay never mind
the 8 oz for life so every time we do a
set of Swing
that's what's keeping me in class I have
no reason to lie to anybody I'm a fat
[__] I go to class to work out but to
give you a little room to eat not to eat
what you want you go to Morton's after
class no no no no I'm just
saying no what do you think I'm [__]
Johnny Bananas I'm just saying in my
mind I settle for a protein shake I
wasn't going to judge you I was going to
do it next week
no they got the
$21.94 that deal no no you change your
where's the Morton I could totally go to
Morton you shoot on [__] I've been
[__] dieing for 4 days I could
totally go to Morton you're killing
yourself to live right now when we get
out of here you can still make it you
can pick up who who you picking up the
little one or the big one oh yeah she's
in yeah is would [__] tear up a steak
yeah she'll sit with you and drink a
glass of wine and not tell Mommy and
nothing isa's all in isa's all [__]
in we going to go for a steak Daddy but
she said to me yesterday you know we can
help each other out every now and
then I said what's that supposed to me
she goes if you give me menes I'll get
you what you need men she loves menes
they had a explosion there last night
like one of the pipes ruptured and so we
went over to go to men she me and the
girls and they were closed and ia's like
I'm not putting up with it and she just
starts knocking on the door and they're
cleaning up knock on the door and the
guy comes to the door and and I'm like
are you guys closed and he's like well
we just don't have any toppings and
isa's like everybody in like starts
pushing through the door everybody in we
can still get ice cream I go yeah so we
got it half off it was great got PE camp
ey I didn't get anything but uh the
girls murdered it I we can help each
other out we can help each other out is
she watching movies on her phone you she
says things that I don't know if she if
she gets them from places because she
says things that blow me away where you
just go where's that where's that coming
from like I I told you we were in Maui
and I'm I got to fly to DC that after
afternoon like at like 2:00 so I'm
leaving at noon so I wake up I'm I'm in
bed with Isla and I roll over and I go
hey baby it's like 6:00 a.m. sun's
coming up I go baby let's go downstairs
get a coffee and I'll get you a donut
and we'll go down and we'll watch a
sunrise then we'll go snorkeling before
anyone wakes up and she says she goes
leave me alone so I go Isa and now I'm
like now I'm like now I'm rolled over
and I got my head in her hip like right
right between her hip and her ribs I go
baby wake up me and go downstairs get a
coffee get a donut chocolate milk we'll
watch a s come up and then we'll go
snorkeling and she Joey I swear to you
she rolls over looks at me she goes
you're tugging on a tiger's tail and
went back to bed that's that [__] kid
she just and I go and my head like she I
told you I I've told this joke a million
times but when she was a baby she sat on
my chest when I when I was waking up sat
on my chest woke me up and goes guess
what's in my hand and I was like I now
now I'm [__] panicking I'm like I
don't know she goes a punch in the mouth
and [__] hit me and I remember saying
to her I was like this is really
important Isla I go did you come up with
that on your own cuz I'm going to tell
that on stage tonight and she was like
yeah yeah I just thought of it I gra it
looks like a punch like if you put
something in your hand it could be a
quarter or a punch I was like [__] that
brain you know it's not it's like I I
say it it's not like going to be useful
to society in any way that will reap the
benefits but someone's going to reap the
benefits of it with a [__] pistol on
a table pound of coke this is how you
get rid of a body that's Isa you're
tugging on a tiger's tail you're tugging
on a tiger's tail and she went right
back to bed yeah and she says St like
that when you [__] with her she starts
going you're pushing a lot of buttons
one of them is going to be red and
you're like what I know a dude her brain
works very differently now don't get me
wrong she's dyslexic as [__] she's
getting her ass handed to her in school
like I mean every year we're like is she
going to the next grade because she has
a really hard time in school can't can't
read barely at all like but the truth is
man her brain just sees the world very
differently and she makes she's so funny
I mean they were trying to do yo mama
jokes and her rendition of yo mama jokes
were so esoteric they didn't make sense
anymore yo mama's so poor she has nuts
in her purse every now and then CU she
wants to snack and you're like what but
her brain just it spins out you know
like it just has I don't know man now G
is a genius yeah [__] G you got no
she's perfect the homework you to tell
her what to do independent she reads
very nice very sweet very sweet very
loving she's in honors classes no drama
no drama no drama going to be a knockout
no boys yet nothing nothing uh still
believes in like Santa Claus like I mean
the youngest sixth grader in the world
still believes in Santa still believes
in the tooth fairy that Willie we we
hide a little elf on the shelf
everywhere she still believes that he's
magic and he watches her like I she's
just like the she's so perfect and isa's
already skeptical she on one of I have
this Joey I have this and I will post it
on Twitter today I have this it is one
of my favorite things ever Isa on her
Santa Claus list maybe like two years
ago three years ago one was um you know
I want a Polly Pocket I want a I want uh
la la loopsies I want uh Barbie camper
and then one of them was I'm not even
[__] with you mind you Joey she was
was 6 years old she wrote I want proof
that your gang is real to Santa I want
proof that your gang is real and then
she took a [__] GoPro last Christmas
and hit it on the mantle and started it
and I went and I S I saw it she was
trying to catch Santa Claus started it
so I go in I [__] we I I see it it's
[__] blinking red light in the middle
of our living room so I go in I put
everyone to bed I have the video on my
computer on my computer I won't post it
cuz I don't until they don't believe in
Santa I go into my bedroom I go to sleep
I don't go to sleep I just sit there for
like [__] 5 minutes lights out
everyone Waits I just walk right back in
I have a white Mitten on I have the
bells in my hand I get I have a
flashlight in my hand I get underneath
the by the uh by the fireplace I jump
down and jingle the bells right I flash
the flashlight around Priscilla doesn't
move she just sees it to me just stares
go puts her head back down I I reach my
hand up with the Mitten I grab the GoPro
I turn it around and then I turn on the
lights and I start walking around with
bells and moving presents around then I
take that V and then I let it play all
[__] night long I then take that
video and I simply splice out me walking
in the room on on iMovie I have I have
[__] 40 minutes of video I splice out
me walking in the room and then it just
looks like the room just SATs still and
all of the sudden out of nowhere Sanic
shows up at the end and then the next
day I go guys the gopro's dead and ia's
like Dad Dad we got Santa we got Santa
so I I mind you I've done all the
[__] work already I've already it
took two seconds you know how easy it is
to splice out me walking into the room
and getting under the thing and I just
take it and I [__] let it play out
for the Whole 30 minutes like 30 45
minutes I let it watch the whole thing
and they're like I don't see it fast
forward fast forward I'm like all right
I'm fast forward and all of a sudden
they see Santa and isa's like holy [__]
they see the glove come up they see it
turn around and Georgia starts looking
at me like mind you this is I I thought
she'd Stop Believing she'd start looking
at me like like she found Jesus like
holy [__] like Santa's [__] real and
I was like I don't know what to tell you
guys my dad looks at me he's like I
think you're [__] your kids up but
yeah man they still [__] believe I
love I love I love the the fun of being
a parent like when they're still young
and they're not they're not broken yet
they're not [__] doing drugs I mean
I'm I was at sixth grade I was like two
I was one year off from drinking in
sixth grade I drank in seventh grade was
the first time I drank first time I got
drunk though it was in ninth grade if I
drank I sipped alcohol you know to to
just to be cool in seventh grade you
look at them you I look at my
three-year-old and I her spirit is still
alive like you know she hasn't bumped
into life yet she hasn't gotten hit at
school yet there's still she's still her
mind still hasn't wrapped around around
something like why that happened she
thinks life is just ice cream and
spaghetti and hot dogs and you know
Daddy throws her up in the doesn't hurt
yet yeah and it's really interesting to
watch and to think that that was you at
one time you know every day a piece of
her I go that was me that's [__] me
you know I got her first report card
today how was it it was all good except
you know she doesn't ask questions she
don't like
questions
do she don't know nothing did you give
her a little something for that she gets
home cuz I gave her a hug there then
they gave me the report card and I just
walked home very nonchalant when we got
home I looked at it and then my wife
goes and did you actually read that and
I go [__] yeah this is what a parent
does you're supposed to see where
they're slipping that is [__] genius
she doesn't like she doesn't ask
questions she doesn't like questions she
don't ask questions she don't like
questions she a got time for it you know
what I'm saying that's that's my child
I'm very proud of that fact that you
know what's with the questions anyway
what's with the questions what are you
writing a book you don't need to know
nothing listen man I'm Mercy I'm here
what else do you need to know yeah
that's it don't worry about nothing you
know it's so weird I came from my house
and my mom would look at me straight in
the eye and go listen what [__]
happens in the house is those three
monkeys M OA you know this this and this
yeah and I had to live by that like I
had to live by that like by the time and
I was telling uh my friend uh Julian
that when when I was a kid by the time I
was eight people would talk to me about
drugs I knew everything about drugs yeah
I had seen Coke in my house and I
couldn't say nothing I couldn't say you
want to see I'll show you pot no I
couldn't say nothing
yeah I had to act like a [__] [__]
and I played double agent for years it
took me years to get on a podcast and
talk about that [__] I would never that
early life what I saw as a young kid
that's a double life type you can't talk
about you know when I saw my stepdad
shoot niiko picadillo on her 48th Street
I wasn't allowed to go back on Monday
and say hey guys [__] sat Night Live and
[__] your dead being a fireman let me
tell you what I saw Saturday night at
the [__] Santa Ria party I couldn't
say that I kept that for years I didn't
tell somebody I saw my stepdad shoot a
guy or my stepdad beat up a guy in the
Bronx over a [__] dog I never told
that to anybody because can we pause for
one second there's a lot of interference
there's a what there's a lot of noise
from something hold on is it my phone I
don't
know can you
[Music]
you sounds good all right there we go
thanks sounds better y are we back yep
okay what time is it I don't I'm not
late yet am I 1:20 oh I'm fine I'm fine
we got [__] tons of time but I had
talked to you guys about something I
spoke to Lee about it this is [__]
crazy when I was young when I got left
back and all that in the sixth and
seventh grade in the afternoons I became
friends with this family and I would go
to their house they were one of many
families and uh they were really nice
people people they were Spanish and I go
over there and I had two girls and a boy
and we became friends and one day my mom
died you know we were all good friends
and they came up to me at the wake and
they were like listen man just so you
know we'd like for you to be raised in a
Cuban tradition if you'd like move in
with us you know and I continued to go
over there even though I didn't move in
with them I continued to go over there
and visit with them and talk with them
and you know and by 82 one day I I just
uh knew knew they had money in the house
and I walked in the back door and just
took some money from the house you know
and and I did it a couple times and I
think they knew it was me you know they
had a back door and they had three kids
and they always knew that you could walk
in the back door you know and uh and I
felt guilty I saw them out one night and
I could see the way they were looking at
me they were a little angry at me and
then life moved on and I came out of
here and I never really thought about it
I felt bad you know and one day I went
to the comedy show and day they were one
girl came then the girl came again then
the girl came again with her sister and
they came and they talked to me and the
other day I'm like I'm thinking of
saying something to him you know because
they invited me like you know my dad
still talks about you he's really proud
of you come by and say hello you
know and I was telling me I don't know
what to do oh well [__] I'm thinking
about that and Bam Thanksgiving comes
and I call my buddy in Jersey who was my
roommate and bould while I was waiting
to get sentenced so here I am living
with George
I get in trouble for kidnapping okay I
get out I get I go to county jail for a
month to get bailed out I get bailed out
me and George stay in that apartment
like a week later we get
robbed we get [__] robbed like just
robbed our apartment gets robbed we had
in Boulder we lose the TV the VCR the
stereo they took [__] from our room okay
then about a week later I slit my arm
open okay with a dish oh and I didn't
get stitches I passed out I slept for
[__] two days I got up and I bandaged
it up and I put vitamin E on and the
scar went away and I lived to tell us
another story I just had this run of bad
luck so it's March of
88 and I need a place to live George
wants to go home he can't take him no
more he's Tapped Out machine guns the
place getting raided you know this is
just a house of Doom yeah George wasn't
used to that lifestyle my buddy from
Jersey I was and I felt really bad I
wished him luck he let I had to find the
roommate and I called this one guy and
guess what he's from my hometown in
Jersey only 10 years old he know we know
the same people I'm moving with him he's
great I'm paying rent I got a great
bedroom I got the side of the house but
I see this guy's up all night and he
does sniffles and people come over at
all hours of the night I know what this
guy's doing yeah well guess what I bump
into a stash I'm lifting weights in the
garage and I'm looking at these paint
cans I'm like why does this guy have so
many paint cans and I go over the paint
can they all fill with ounces and two
three ounces of blow guy would get like
a pound every two weeks from this
Mexican dude that his parents had a gym
in a part of Mexico and this is where
they had steroids and this is where
Stallone would take people to prepare
them for Rockies and all his Rambo
movies and this is where they at first
this is in the 80s where Stalone we go
guar or what I don't even know uh uh one
the one the real pretty one he would the
guy his parents had a gym but their real
business was cocaine yeah and this guy
would drop it off once a month and he'd
had the cash and the paint cans I never
touched his cash I always took a little
bit of coke like a gram some nights I
tick five gram some nights i' TI a half
ounce I always felt [__] guilty but
he was free basing so he wouldn't know
how much he really did oh yeah he would
tell me a week later Jesus Christ last
week I woke up I did 40 Gams that can't
be that's because I had taken seven of
them you know last night I did 40 grams
you think I'm kidding you yeah 30 years
ago in ' 87 this guy told me that he
used to take a hit of crap of Cree base
and blood would come out of his ass so
anyway to tell you a long story short I
talked to him
Thursday and he tells me that he had a
heart attack you believe this I'm
shocked he's still you're right but was
it immediately like when he snorts it a
little bit blood comes out of his so
he's telling me how he went to uh he
went to
uh he had a heart attack he went to the
doctor and he found out he had cancer he
had dormant cancer from having sex in
Vietnam it's a type of of of sex disease
that goes into your body and it sits
dormant and from him smok and it
activated he didn't get the cancer from
smoking it went to his throat but theyve
got it out in time and I go how' you
know you have it he goes I was spitting
blood pure blood I was just spitting it
from time to time and the listen guys I
could tell you a thousand stories this
guy was a sweetheart in fact at my
wedding he came over to me goes there's
something I really got to ask you this
guy is [__] up yeah and he goes
there's something I really got to ask
you I go what's that he goes was it you
that was taking my cocaine yeah I go no
it wasn't I lied to his face it's your
wedding day you deserve it I listen
listen let me tell you something I uh I
was really embarrassed about having a
lie to a good friend of mine yeah and
always ate away at me you know what
every time I go to Jersey sometimes we
hook up we just got a Cuban sandwich
he's a good guy and he's a smart guy and
I came in here Friday and I told Lee I
go Lee it's eating me alive I don't know
what to do so I called my man back
yesterday and I spoke to him a little
bit and I go listen I'm going to Jersey
next week if there's anything I could do
to help you and he goes you know I
looked into something Edibles I said I
was thinking the same thing so I called
a few friends of mine I got his address
I called a few friends of mine I said
send him some boxes and hopefully we'll
get together you know what me going
looking him in the eye now and telling
them that I robbed them is not going to
make things better but it's imagine how
it's it's amazing how life works out you
know that Spanish family I'm going to go
see them when I go back yeah and uh and
and the Spanish CR I'm still tempted to
say hey without saying what I need to
say here I'm sorry and you guys know why
I'm sorry yeah why open up a can of
[__] worms I still remember one
morning just being in a coma one Friday
morning like just waking up [__] up in
the night before and one of my friends
knocking on the glass where I was living
and me looking over we're were living in
a basement apartment and me and him had
beds on the floor like animals and I'm
looking at the glass and I'm going come
on I'm out here and just me going to the
bathroom throwing water in my face
brushing my teeth combing my hand
getting the car I'm going where are we
going to that I go let's go downtown you
know it's 9:00 in the morning let's go
rob
and I would go downtown I go park the
car right here and let me go from door
to door see what's going on and one day
just going you know what give me a ride
by these people's house I'm going around
the back the door was open I still
remember the exact day and I'm going in
the house going in like this living room
and they had one of those beers from a
German Fest yeah you see those mugs a
Stein that you open up the top there a
lid [__] yeah and something just
attracted me to the Stein and I went in
there and I stuck my hand in it I took
out
$450 in my world at that time it was
like $10,000 [__] dollars I ran
downstairs it was maybe 10 to 10 and I
made this kid take me to
135th and Amsterdam to some [__]
Colombians who had a disco in a basement
and who had chickens and they had a DJ
booth and they would play music and
these [__] immigrants would sit there
dancing like to to rap music music uh
black people everywhere looking at the
people in the just don't it was
hysterical yeah and I go in there at
2:00 in the afternoon to buy [__]
eight balls and these people would be
disco do you understand me what I'm
telling you guys that I would go in
there at 2: in the afternoon and without
exaggerating they'd be 20 to 30 people
on the Dance Floor already dancing
drinking at the bar snor and blow and
who were they were they like people who
work night people they had to they had
to work nice no people who didn't work
at all this is people who snorted blow
who snorts blow and dance and goes to
work at Night Le say you barely got up
at 5: in the afternoon you got to be at
work at 700 you're not going to get up
at 12:00 go do blow drink and then oh
you know what I got to go to work now
the cocaine is gone [__] no sober these
people didn't work these were people who
we had like they were like Street
dealers you know those scenes in movies
where it's 2: in the afternoon there's
three sitting there doing their fingers
and they're all hotted up waiting for
the guys to tell to suck their dick yeah
what what are you doing in the room why
are you here I never understood those
scenes like why the woman would sit
there all day why not oh Jesus Christ go
somewhere go for a
walk it was all their girlfriends and
you would walk in the booth in those
days it
was $300 for an aall and it was that
good this is this is the $300 is a lot
right in those days this was this was
the spring of
82 spring February of 82 January of
82 it was $300 you got a half a gram
free and it was beautiful cocaine and
you'd walk into the Disco the guy would
make you go into the DJ booth
M the D the scale was under the thing he
put it on there was two turn tables
three turntables and in the middle there
was a gap for the [__] scale and on
top of the door there was a slash for
two different types of coke he lay a
line out for you while you were waiting
he cut it up for you he was spinning
music while he was weighing up the cat
he put aluminum for he gave it you
walked back into your car in amsterdan
Avenue can you [__] believe
that and I had like a whatever I had
balance 150 I gave the kid driving the
yard stick and we probably went to the
cityan a somewhere and that was what we
did for the [__] 450 I robbed him for
I always felt guilty about that that's
why I still never forgot what I did so I
don't know if I give him a gift
certificate I don't know if I give him a
check I don't know if I just apologize I
just apologize something like that I
don't think if you give him them I don't
know I don't know I I all I said was
just say sorry and then see where it
goes like I always think to myself like
do you have regrets do you have regrets
Lee yeah of course like things that you
go God I wish I could make that right
yeah tons of them like
what uh I have a bad relationship with
my brother really yeah how come we we've
never got along it just at this point
it's not over one anything it's just
after five minutes we're just always at
each other's throats it's it's just it's
a natural thing now it's weird really
yeah it's okay who know maybe in the
future
but as of right now more relationship
regrets where you stop talking I have a
friend I haven't spoken to I have a
couple of that and I don't understand I
have a friend
now my best friend the one I took the
picture with that I tweeted to you when
I was young [__] uh I called him up I
invited him up I said listen I'm coming
up to Jersey if you want to come up get
a hotel room we'll hang
out uh you know whatever you want to do
we'll smoke dope you come with me to
Long Island the whole [__] deal
that's how young I was good God you
[__] how old were you 18 holy [__]
mustache and everything mustache and
everything and he was fine
and when I saw that picture when his
niece sent me that picture I realized
how much I loved him and I missed him
yeah and the last 10 years I've seen him
once at the Gotham Comedy Club in New
York outside we split a 500 milligram
brownie that he called me 3 days later
and he goes I'll never eat that again
that was horrible I couldn't even think
for three days but he's my brother he
he's gave me a place to live when I was
young and yeah so [__] honestly you
ever you ever have a and you this going
to happen to you you you come from a big
family you know what sometimes you just
want to hang out with your sisters yeah
but they got to bring their kids and the
boyfriend and the boyfriend's mother and
the boyfriend's father opposite for me
sometimes my sisters just want to hang
out with me and not my whole family cuz
if they hang out with my family they
hang out with my daughters more I don't
even talk to him and then Leanne they
love Leanne so they talk to Leanne and
so like for Thanksgiving we all my whole
family everyone went down to Tampa to
see my parents new house and we go and
the girls
left Friday at Friday morning and I
didn't leave till Friday night so I hung
out at my parents house for the day like
a kid like like with my sisters and it
was so cool cuz I never get to hang out
with my sisters like just alone where
you get to talk and go and you see their
personalities and them not having to
take care of your kids or cater to to
your wife or my mom and my sister it was
really fun it's different and that's all
I said to him he goes well do you know
what the reservation for the hotel room
was like I never made it for you because
you never told me so he goes if I come
up how many beds can you get me I go why
he goes because my daughter and her
[__] boyfriend want to come up now no
listen man I grew up with this guy yeah
you know there completely different
things I don't know you bur Cher one day
you're going to call me and said Isa did
this and in my mind I'm going go it's
time to take Isa for a ride and put a
gun to her head and explain to her this
is what's going to happen to her if she
keeps [__] around we'll take it to a
[__] neighborhood women are [__]
[__] around doing drugs I'm well
that's where you going to end up yeah
that's what you want we let you here
here 50 go why [__] around why put your
mom through this anymore you're killing
your mom you're killing your sister and
they'll look at you and go no no take me
home and then you got them you got them
sometimes you got to take kids to the
murky [__] Waters sometimes you got
to take them to the murky Waters and go
this is what you want you want to kill
me here you want 50 right I tell you
what I'll give you 500 don't come back
I'll tell your mom that you just left
with the dog and they'll just look at
you don't just look at you sometimes you
got to take a kid and go this what you
want look at that girl is that what you
want to do with you like it's going to
happen I can tell you two things I'm
sorry BR or I can say look I love you
bro it's time to take her for a ride
yeah and you know we'll smack her around
we'll take her to a [__] yum yum
house and tie her up and let her see
what [__] she loves yum yums she loves
Yum Yum Donuts oh everybody does who
doesn't love Yum Yum Donuts Lee is that
customer of the month she loves yum y
you see they put a picture of Lee
running out with a box of Yum Yum Donuts
out of this [__] thing I haven't got
a Yum Yum Donuts in Mon and then you no
it wasn't me c he had the bright idea to
have Donuts on Thanksgiving so before
Jiu-Jitsu so I went and that's the only
time of I got recognized with two boxes
of Donuts two boxes of Yum Yum Donuts
Mexican people recognized and put his
picture on tundo and [__] and I keep
talking about being healthy and I have
two dozen donuts and this go like hey
like I had two of those coconut Donuts
at Jujitsu and that night I'm sitting
there it's 1:00 in the morning I'm H and
[__] listen once I break midnight I just
go deeper than deep I just start eating
everything that's around me I go on the
balcony and smoke and I just sit there
and watch [__] whatever's on TV oh my
God and I went in the kitchen and on top
of the baby chair was the box of donuts
I opened it up and it was two chocolate
coconuts I picked them both up with one
finger had to and I [__] ate the bo
[__] no I don't know I didn't know what
to do for a few days whether I apologize
to these people yeah
so what I'm going to do is I I told uh
my friend Jersey I would hook him up and
I called three manufacturers uh one of
them being goomies and they're going to
help him out and uh send them a bunch of
[__] today today they're like we'll
double [__] send them you know I said
just build me just get it over to the
guy you know he's in Bay and he's got
the the [__] cancer the other people
I don't know how to apologize cuz I
didn't know they'd be in my life at this
point in the [__] game yeah you know
so it's kind of weird how life works out
sometimes sometimes you do something 30
years earlier I have a bunch of friends
I don't talk to I have a bunch of people
I I I to stop talking to and then and
then you grow so much in the time that
you're not talking to them that to talk
to them now would seem I mean honestly I
have thought about it like do I you know
do I reach out to people and and you
know that I that I feel like I don't
have any real ill will towards but I
just don't speak to anymore right yeah
but then I go I've changed so much and I
don't know if I can be the person that I
was when I was friends with him then who
I was then was not who I am
today what what the [__] do you know
what do you mean what do you know how
much you changed let give give them the
opportunity to decide yeah but some some
of them I don't some of them if you feel
sometimes that they I made a few
mistakes yeah the worst thing about
social media is we got a bold re dose of
reality everybody in this room got a
bold dose of reality salute everybody in
this room and people listen to the
podcast got a cold dose reality on
Facebook I think it was Facebook because
we all contacted somebody we should and
then we even got them on the phone to
make matters worse and once we started
talking to him say Lee this hasn't
happened to you yet but it's happened to
me I've been out of high school for 30
[__] years and it's it you know how
long have you been out of high school
for 20 years 20 years so now there's
people that you bump into that you open
the line of communication up with and
it's a [__] big mistake now I think
of it twice before I say to them hey
send me over your [__] number because
I have made so many mistakes thinking
that that was the same person I was
friends with 20 years ago their
priorities changed my priorities changed
their [__] uh chi has weakened
because you know my CH has gotten
weakened so with different people and
now I'm trying to rekindle this
friendship from
1981 he's a Buddhist I don't get high no
more you know I had one guy that I loved
growing up and I saw him on Facebook and
I immediately reached out and the last
10 years he had lived in Long
Beach and it was crazy and then he
brought up a situation and right where I
knew I had to get away from this because
he brought up a situation from 1983 that
he had somebody had contacted him that I
hadn't mentioned his sister's name on
the podcast which was two his sister sat
on gallano bottles in a [__] Li at a
[__] strip club yeah you know and I
tell the story all the time Tina
everybody knows when you meet people
when I see people now from my hometown
the third paragraph is remember the Mel
lands in the chick used to sit on the
gallano bottle your sister sat in the
gallano bottle people going to mention
that forever in their death [__] bed
yeah people going to say I want to thank
my mother I want to thank Tina for
sticking a gallano bottle up her ass all
on Thanksgiving when my spirits were
down she'd sit on a gallano bottle she'd
take a bottle of Budweiser pop it put
the bottle jerk herself off take all the
beer the bottle into a monkey and then
spray it at the
audience in 1982 okay I was a young man
I witnessed it and people people would
know he was her brother they wouldn't
know no so he'd be standing and all of a
sudden oh no Lee would walk over and go
are you going to [__] erotic banana
night tonight because on Wednesday she
had a thing that for $2 they gave you
two frozen bananas
and you gave them to the strippers they
put them in their [__] and you can eat
them you eat the [__] You' eat the
banana I don't like bananas to begin
with no no you alone out of a you like
these [__] bananas these were good
organic bananas
organic people pay big money at Whole
Foods I made that mistake by saying
people's names on podcast by saying by
using real names cuz I cuz I don't I'm
the same as you it's like I'm the same
as you in the sense that there's a there
is no I I was talking to um I was
talking to someone about this the other
day there's no real like you look at
Daniel TSH and he is on stage a very
different person than he is off stage
you don't know who he is off stage all
you know is his Persona on stage off
stage completely different guy there are
a lot of guys like that you know that
who they were on stage was not who they
were off stage but what I always liked
in comedy were the guys where you
couldn't see the character and the ACT
you couldn't differentiate between the
character and the ACT it was the person
that person is who you saw on stage Sam
kenison like Hedberg like all those guys
I just dug like it tell is a guy that is
two different guys you don't know who he
is off stage really anymore you know
like and and you're like me is that the
Joey Diaz on stage is identical to Joey
Diaz off stage maybe it's a little
louder little more hyped a little more
energy maybe there's a lot more uh depth
and ranged to who you are off stage that
you don't show on stage but for the most
part all that depth and I've seen it you
do it before all that depth that you
have you don't give a [__] about sharing
it on stage if you feel like saying
something on a podcast or on stage
you'll [__] say it this is who I am
I'm this is I'm sorry this this you're
getting this and it's it gets confusing
for me because you get you end up
living I end up and it it's just taxing
in a weird way because I end up telling
these stories or writing in my book I
wrote about this girl Jenny powers and I
just I didn't even think I just wrote I
wrote everyone's real name in my book
there was the biggest [__] [__]
mistake big mistake you can only write
the first name or the last name you know
like an that's it yeah I just used
everyone's real names and [__] she
reached out to me and she was like she
was like are you [__] serious like
this is what you thought of me in high
school and I was like uhoh I had to call
my I only have like one friend left
that's like real that's very real where
you can't [__] with him cuz he's been
through it all his name's Cayman he's
real like you tell him one thing is that
[__] him like I when I fell off that
that waterfall I was eating pills a lot
and I was like freaked out I was like
man I'm eating a lot of pain pills to
get through this it hurts but I'm still
enjoying the pain pills I called Cayman
I was like I'm worried he's like d don't
worry man you got to be taken [__] 10
at a time before you start getting
concerned like he's just one of those
real [__] and uh and I I talked
to Cayman about it and he was like that
[__] should remember that was that's
real what are you going to
do everyone's got a better memory of
themselves when they tell it to you oh
in high school I was a [__] a star
baseball player well kind of you you
were first string in a [__] Private
School baseball team you know but like
everyone's got a [__] tainted memory
of themselves but I'm the same way as
you it's like that guy I am on stage is
identical to who I am off stage it's
it's almost like and I don't know if
you'll like this analogy but it's almost
like this Bill Murray effect it's like I
know that people have told me they hung
out with you and I got high with Joey
after a show or I hung out with Joey
after a show he sat we all we went and
eight or something and it's just like a
[__] it's like for you it's not a big
deal for them it's they're hanging out
with the performer does that make sense
like it's it like it's a lot of weight
to them like when I hang out after a
show and I drink people are like can't
believe you're hanging out drinking
you're like well that's what I'll do
that's what I was going to do anyway I
was going to sit here and drink what I
[__] go to my room and drink by
myself but it's it's gets con convoluted
and some people they just went off into
regular life and and their Facebook
profile pages are
all the best part of them it's not the
bad parts where they don't share the
secrets and the things they don't like
all they have is the picture the one
time they flew on a private jet and the
one time they were on a yacht and the
one time they're in Mexico and the one
time they're in Hawaii and their kids
after 40 [__] pictures they pick the
best one and crop out the kid that's got
the lazy eye they those people I don't
I'm not those people and I don't get
those people but those people when they
run into me and you and I think that we
give them like a reflection of what what
we remember the truth to be or what we
see what we remember those times to be
they're just like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa I [__] changed I'm not that guy
n you're still that [__] guy if I'm
this guy you're still that guy and if
you if that's who you were then you can
change you can be different but maybe
you know I got a friend I have a really
good friend who's a very wealthy dude
one of the richest guys in all Tampa and
we used to party a lot I mean we used to
party our whole [__] lives up
until I had Georgia and Isa and we were
in Edmonton for a wedding and we we got
[__] wasted we had a [__] great
time then he got sober and his like I'm
not saying not don't get sober but he
called me up one morning he heard me on
radio and I just was like New Year's Eve
I was drinking champagne and it was like
[__] 8: in the morning and he [__]
pulled me like he said let's meet up so
we met up at like on Davis Island and
I'm with my film crew I'm in in limo
with the people driving you around for
the club taking you to radio I'm done
radio going down to eor City to get some
Cuban food and have a [__] another
cocktail it's like maybe 10 in the
morning now he just looks at me he's
like uh you need to grow up oh last time
I ever spoke to the guy it was one of my
best friends I I went I need to grow up
I'm making a dick load of money working
I'm having a great time I'm not [__]
doing coke at eight in the morning I'm
having some champagne and some drinks
and I got a film crew with me and I'm in
a limo this is if anyone got an
opportunity to be in a limo at 10: in
the morning getting driven around being
treated like a celebrity and someone
opened a bottle of champagne on New
Year's morning you'd [__] have a sip
and I just looked at him and I was like
last time I ever talked to him there's
nothing worse than the people who stop
getting high who get pissed at people
who get high yeah listen I don't do c no
more it's eight years I don't want to do
it you know I don't want to hang out in
the car with somebody like I can't
imagine getting pulled over and you got
an eightball on you and now I got to do
time because of you and I got to go tell
my wife my wife's going to look at me
and go I thought you whatever you know
people who listen to the podcast go
whatever
so but I don't get mad when people do it
you want to come to a show and get
[__] blasted long as you shut the
[__] up I would never ever at all it's
those idiots that don't get high and
judge people they drive me up a [__]
wall and they use it it's who they are
now like I've been clean and so but who
gives a [__] before that you were
sucking dick like everybody else in the
[__] room yeah so go [__] yourself
who gives a [__] that you know there's
too many of those people here that too
yes I used to do drugs so did everybody
else big [__] deal so did everybody
else
you know Guns and Roses you know the
Eagles there's a big con there's a big
thing going on with the Eagles right now
that they're doing something and not
inviting not inviting three of the guys
guys let me tell you what happened to
the eagles they grew up they realized
this was a business Don Henley and Glenn
Fry realized this is a business and
listen we were broken up for 20 years
yeah that's fine but guess what me and
him had number one seven songs and we
acted and we did movies and we did all
this so we kept the Eagles Alive Now Lee
wants to walk in here and get 30% that's
coming to him I can't give it to you Lee
you've been living on Laurel Canyon
telling people you hung out with Tom
Petty when you were a kid I've been out
there doing it so they threw out Don
felda that's the only one that bothers
me really the other two they were there
for one Joe Walsh right well yeah Joe
Walsh was always an employ it's not fair
Joe Walsh show showed up later Don
Felder wrote Hotel California really
yeah but what happened with Don Felder
he's one of these guys that he didn't
need much you know Don Felder didn't
need much Don felder's okay just to make
it simple the kadashian hang out with a
dude that has brown hair and he's
married to a chick with blonde hair
that's Don felder's daughter Don Felder
has been on the Kardashians before
really yes is he
Rich well he didn't need for much but he
still partied so when they had that big
sponsor that big tour in 99 when they
made the comeback and it was $250 a
[__] ticket he had signed paperwork
that he was an employee and they're like
what are you talking about I was there
from the beginning you know he showed up
like hey guys here's the bronze and the
booze and they looked at him they all
had suits on and haircuts and they were
like no we don't even talk to each other
we just play as a band now same thing
happened to The Beach Boys I got really
into the Beach Boys Like couple weeks
ago uh a couple months ago after I saw
that movie love and mercy with uh with
Paul Dano [__] great movie but man
The Beach Boys now I think they're all
employees like Mike love does his own
Beach Boys tour Brian Wilson's got his
own like it's it's a it's bizarre and
they're family they're cousins it's very
interesting you said something I had a
conversation with Slash that was very
interesting and it's true with comedy I
bumped into him one weekend I was flat
bro I was opening for Joe at the Riviera
they paid a 100 a set it was the
midnight show sharer gave you a car to
eat with the employees roast beef with
teeth marks in it and you know bread
with finger oh my God teeth marks in it
little Muffins with fingerprints in them
like the the people like put their
finger through them it's a hor it was a
horrible experience and I walked around
the casino I had no weed Joe didn't
smoke
then you know Joe would get pissed see
if you smoke then this is 99 holy [__]
and I see Slash I had saw him at Burbank
Airport and then now I saw him at the
casino earlier and now there he is just
walking around at 1:30 in the morning I
went up to him I introduced myself I I
met you at the room on Sunset I met on
met brand room then uh Dublin's before
Dublin's what was it
before the union okay it was the union
it was it was first opened by a metaed
and the mov movie star's girlfriend
what's the movie star I met his
roommates with Vince vaugh Vince
Vaughn's earlier girlfriend Mada girl
that had a lot of hair on her
back she was cute as [__] but she had
tons of hair on back my a lot of girl
had tons of hair on her back she was
like a werewolf and [__] I used to look
at her and go how much hair can she
possibly have in a monkey it's like a
[__] bald head I mean she was cute so
they used to book it but to make a long
story short I introduced myself and I
and again I said said to him what really
happened to guns and roses and he asked
me if I was broke and I said yes and he
goes you work hard yes these are going
to be the best times of your
life he goes wait till you're getting
letters from lawyers telling you what
you can and can't say on stage that's
when this changes that's when this
really
changes that's
when people don't justify the work they
did in his case he got a check in the
man
and he freaked out he hired like a
psychic when I first moved to LA in
January
97 the second celebrity I saw was Axel
Rose at Gorky Park gorki Park Gorky Park
is a Russian Park wait there was a movie
called Gorky Park I know that Gorky Park
is a park on Fountain Boulevard over I
over in Hollywood where they play chess
the old Russ and there's a farmers
Market on Mondays and Tuesdays yes okay
big swing sets we used to do the girls
birthdays there it's on gor it's on uh
uh down the block from the Guitar Center
yeah right there right down the block
from the guitar me and Josh Wolf lived
in that building there and then over is
Garder over is uh where Mitch Hedberg
live with Nick depalo and then over is
kerson but right there that used to when
we first moved here they sold nickel
bags of weed there the Russians in the
back of the Park big swings back there
yes in the b in the back big swings big
Park well back one day I'm walking out
and there's Axel Rose and like this the
Dodge Viper oh yeah yeah yeah remember
the old remember the Dodge Viper like a
yellow one like it stuck out like a
[__] like a like a black dude in
Nashville like he just stuck out
Jack let me give some shout outs and
we'll get you out of here yeah I gotta
go get Isa
oh hey this weekend I'm at the Irvine
Improv are you this weekend Thursday
Friday Saturday uh no Friday Saturday
Sunday oh beautiful that's Friday Satur
and then what other dates you have
that's it I'm oh well then I I start up
in uh January and I'm on tour until June
so go to bb.com check out my Vlog on my
YouTube page I'm doing them I'm doing
them try to do them daily or by daily
twice a week three times a week so go to
my YouTube channel subscribe and uh and
then check out my podcast Joey we're
going to do a parter going to come on
next week well after I go to Jersey I'm
going to see these two people yeah I'm
going to see what happens and see how
react we'll talk about this we'll
continue it let me give uh 100 p.m 1 pm
Hebrew a shout out Marty 101
Hoster Chris Arena Leon Vega my main man
holding it down in Spain JT always on
there [__] around krusi Chris Brendan
no n Crush Gill Chris Brendan stuff the
main bastard and Boston John you all get
shout out this Saturday I will be at
Governor's in Long [__] Island
[__] and then December 17th St
Lazaro's birthday I will be at the
American Comedy Club in San Diego Lee
will not be there he will be in on a
Love Shack tying mama up getting here
beating about Atlanta what what's her
name about who what's the singer sheana
Del Alana Del re telling you about her
feelings Alana Del re and what it means
to her when she hears those songs sounds
like and you got to sit there and take
that ear beat until you finally say
listen what's going on with that dick
sucking you had in mind cuz for [__]
uh I got to get this cabin [__]
rocking and [__] but you sit there and
take you probably sit in the cabin and
text with
it
no you gotta text her come on over here
sniff this [__]
Jude nut sack oh my
God it's so funny to see Leo from when I
walked in and we had a we had a yeah
coherent nice conversation to see him
blinking off over in the corner oh my
God I had 600 milligrams cuz you know
can we can I say what you said when you
came in of course yeah he were like
what's what's a good amount to have if I
just want to go to sleep and I was like
well it's not a good question to ask me
he goes my my my limits are really they
I'm not saying I'm at Joey's level but
I'm close
I told yeah I I just would I would love
to be able to take a little bit of an
edible and have it work like a Xanax and
just put you to sleep or like an ambient
be the healthiest way to go what the
[__] do you think I do every night how
do you think I fall asleep the best I
got [__] pills at the house and I'll
tell you what there's some nights I take
the pills just to give me a different
high but you want to sleep like a
[__] baby yeah I got the recipe what
is it one of these Stars maybe two of
these Stars Joey Joey Joey you realize
that is there that would [__] cause
how many milligrams is that let's
pretend you eat 250 let me tell you
what's going to happen to you you're
going to sleep seven [__] hours
before you even know what hit you you're
going to wake up with a pillow over your
face you're look around your room no
like just still going to be on you're
going to be thirsty as [__] you're going
to get up you're going to go pee you're
going to go drink some water Isa one of
them is going to ask you are we going to
do this and you go hold on I'll be right
back you're going to go right back into
that bed and sleep three more hours
it'll be the best 10 hours life plus if
you've worked out it's going to clean
all the acid out of your muscles really
and you're going to feel like a new man
I popped 375 MGS yesterday then I went
home and I popped two [__] Z BOS and
I smoked another gbo on top of that
about 12:30 zbo and a gbo Oh by 1:00 I
was on fire in that living room I turned
the TV off it took me 10 minutes just to
get up you understand
me I love those but once I got up I went
right to that bedroom and went I woke up
this morning I didn't even know where I
was I didn't know what country I had to
drink a big cup of coffee yeah and I had
to talk to them for a little while just
to get my speech back and [__] like that
and then just to get my speech back sure
you got to get your speech back cuz it's
all [__] up oh my
God [__] yes well have fun in uh you
listen man I read something very
interesting that's not surprising to me
what's that that uh prescription pills
are down
because people eat medical marijuana
it's not a it's not a surprise to me God
forbid somebody in your family get some
to type of cancer and the radiation this
guy Manny was telling me a story how he
he stopped eating he stopped eating he
was it wasn't even enjoyable no more I
couldn't taste food and then he ate the
last thing he thought a can of Chef boy
Rd he goes to ravioli and it brought him
back to being a kid so he went back to
the supermarket he bought a bunch of
cans of that and then opened up as a
appetite you know what I'm saying so
this [__] at night I tell you this is
the best I don't give a [__] When
anybody tells you and even if you don't
like Edibles you get something that's
strong and you just take a little bite
off it you be surprised you I'm teasing
you wouldn't know what are those Inda or
sativa or just a hybrid you want to go
to sleep or you want to ask
questions you know what I'm saying I
want to go to sleep what's what's the
difference what's the difference what
are you hippie what you go to this
farmers market talk about juty and [__]
like that no I wish Mercy could come
into that too do you ever eat Edibles no
okay so all you only time I've ever
eaten edbl is with you okay so this is
all you need I tell you this in a
sincere way this should last you this
should last you two
weeks in two weeks I'm talking about
seven nights a week this is seven
nights take a piece here take a piece
now knowing you because we're family you
I'm GNA cleanse okay
you're going to drink a glass of wine
which is the igniter oh really sure you
know what happens to me if I drink a
glass of red wine and eat a [__] star
yeah you don't want to know I have to go
to the hospital really really oh my
Godly you will get [__] up if you
drink the wine first and smoke reefer
you will get sick you will puke if you
drink the wine first and then smoke you
will P you will puke yeah you'll get a
bad headache and you'll get sick I've
never had good experience smoking and
drinking at the same time I've never
been able to Nei love it I love it but
let me tell you something I'll tell you
what you do get one of those Club W
bottles right tonight is she coming over
no perfect you eat a because you try it
by yourself because now you have
something to offer her don't do it with
her because if you have a bad night then
this wasn't that good no really you look
like a [__] jerk off but I tell you
what you eat one of these you need 300
right now you need you ate six so you're
damaged for today right but tomorrow you
eat two
stars and you drink you get a glass of
wine and you take two sips out of it and
see what happens well that's the thing
you're going to feel the best you felt
ever it's going to change the way and
then little by little but you follow I
mean this is to sleep I'm not talking to
go out because the red wine will [__]
zap you okay you drink white wine or red
wine a red wine see that that that alone
I don't know how you know a glass of red
wine is one of the healthy if you take
care of your body yeah drink red wine
and [__] take time to make something
that day with garlic in it you will live
to be a 100 oh I got garlic and and uh
and uh and broccoli sauce in the in the
[__]
fridge from Chinese people no no no I
just I made it I made like roasted
trying to be healthy this month yeah no
so if you chop that garlic up and you
drink a little bit of red wine in that
now listen people will get them differ
with you if you drink a bottle of red
wine that's a complete different
situation but a glass of red wine will
never kill anybody I don't give a [__] I
know I'm living proof I don't drink I
don't have a taste to drink when I go on
a plane if I remember the Southwest
coupons and you know even when I fly
first class I got an upgrade I'm always
shy to ask yeah like Delta has the
description of the menus like
Nutty Nutty this and nutty this and I'm
always like maybe I should get a glass
of wine but I know I got too [__] up
yeah I don't I like it's interesting I
haven't drank Fed Up haven't drank in uh
4 days I'm a I'm a big drinker by all no
[__] Sherlock but but uh I don't miss it
like I don't I don't have one I'm not
one of those personalities that needs to
drink to have a good time or needs to
drink to do something or needs to drink
at the end of the night I I'm more about
rewarding myself with like [__]
anything just like [__] Pizza like
I'm about rewards I want to reward
myself that's where I'm [__] that's
the interesting thing was when I get
into these healthy modes I find myself
denying myself anything and it's just
odd I have a question for you cuz I saw
on your Twitter how is the cauliflower
pizza pizza crust [__] amazing okay
come on because Paula made that and it's
okay it's not amazing did she it was
amazing it was she made it it was good
but it was that's not like pizza did she
but I'm a pretty good
cook she's I mean she's pretty good I it
tasted okay but I was like it's not well
first of all I spiced it up lot a lot of
garlic on top okay and then I and I used
a good sauce on top I used Buffalo
mozzarella so I had like nice good
mozzarella on top and uh and I [__]
loved it i' I'd have it again the only
problem is it's just no carbs it's not
healthy there's a ton of cheese in there
right it's not like I'm I'm looking to
be healthy also all right I should go I
got to go pick up Isa go ahead go do
your thing I love you happy holidays
thank you for coming on don't forget my
main man is an Irvine this weekend if
you done KN nothing I was there last
weekend the [__] great room the unami
Burger is delicious don't oh [__] whoami
burgers are I forgot that's right you're
going to [__] blood for four [__]
days is there a bathroom up here Le yes
there
is and I love that you came on give my
best of the [__] family you know I
love you guys I love you as usual as
usual do not forget our main sponsor I
love him with all my heart meundies
meundies is just a complete different
experience as an underwear for Comfort
they keep your nut sack in I mean let's
talk about underwear and needs to be
comfy snug in all the right places it's
got to look good feel good and smell
good you don't just want to wear
underwear that's comfy you want the
world's most comfortable underwear and
that's meundies all right every pair of
meundies is made of micro mold doll
fabric which doesn't sound sexy but once
you feel your meundies you'll never go
back to that regular white shitty
looking underwear again with meundies
you'll feel more comfortable than ever
before meundies has tons of different
colors to choose from and it's the only
place that you find styles for both men
and women and new signature design every
month they also just land launched a new
boxer line it's like wearing nothing at
all only better they sent me the long
ones and the short ones un [__]
believable with the holidays around the
corner meundies makes the perfect gift
okay so trust me these are not your
parents stocking stuffers these are not
your parents stocking stuffers do me a
favor go to me ./ jooy right now get 20%
off your first order plus all orders in
the US and Canada free shipped that's
how they do it Mees even has a money
back guarantee if you don't love your
first pair you get to keep it and keep
the refund and they'll get a full refund
you literally have nothing to lose order
before December 13th and me andies will
arrive in time for Christmas that's
December 13th and meundies will arrive
in time for Christmas Christmas for 20%
off your first order at world's most
comfortable underwear head to
meundies.com jooy right now that's
meundies.com
jooy right now number two stay black
brother number two hit.com my main dun I
love H it h it does not play you're
looking to stay healthy you don't want
the
flu shroom Tech immune you're looking
for more endurance when you work out
shroom Tech sport you're looking for
better protein an organic protein you
know a plant protein nothing that like
it's very sing in the stomach hemp
protein I love it with all the chocolate
it's delicious couple ice cubes some
water a banana some peanut butter it
that's what I had for dinner last night
I love on it I love the hemp Force
protein but do me a favor do do yourself
a favor go to hit.com right now and
press in church boom and get 10% off
your first order they also have the stay
on a program you give them the credit
card it comes right to your do on a
monthly don't cost you nothing all right
that's how good on it is on the third uh
losies or.com from now on no more nailed
at life that done with vapor pens go to
losies
eros.com right now I want to thank an it
I want to thank meundies.com I want to
thank Blue Apron Club W all our sponsors
uh who else uh texture I want to thank
everybody for the love and support
nailed at life uh Hy sigs you're all a
bunch of bad [__] support these
guys don't forget Long Island Saturday
night December 17th long uh San Diego
California Lee what do you got cooking
[__] just flying you radio flying
G radio d
i what you're what yeah just find radi
me think that's it yep that's it that's
all you got for Uncle Joey that's all I
got right now man all right my brother
Lee's going to take care of the cats
while I'm gone he's my brother I also
want to congratulate lately he's doing
his first jiu-jitsu tournament this
weekend over at John Jack Machado toys
for whatever all I got to say is uh I
don't have the balls to do a competition
Lee's going to go up there he's been
working hard and from the bottom of my
heart I'm very [__] proud of you Lee
because this is going to change you as a
person this is going to change you as a
man for a long time you're either going
to love it they're either going to sit
on your face and break your
elbow or you're going to go in there on
Monday and really kick the [__] out of
it and I'm really proud of you man that
you even get the balls to do it so
congratulations win or lose you're a
[__] winner you don't lose on this
move I'll do it I'm I'm happy I'm doing
it this is what the church is all about
it's trying things and doing it nothing
happens on the couch nothing it's going
to be interesting he's 280 lbs who gives
a [__] but you're you're
220 230 280 if you [__] really lay on
top of him so you got every opportunity
in the world and just the fact that
you're going it's going to rise you as a
human being watch you're going you're
going to tell me on Monday you feel
completely different Everything feels
different because you did something for
yourself man and I'm really proud of you
from the bottom of my heart so
congratulations thank you man for taking
the move and beside that I love you
[__] with all my heart I want
to thank ber chry I want to thank you
guys for listening and for the support
and for keeping Savage D at number one I
can't ask for anything else from you
guys thank you very much you're helping
me prove a point so uh thank you have a
great week again we'll be back mon uh
we'll be back next Thursday December
10th I'm taking Monday and Wednesday off
with the family but I'll be periscoping
you [__] so stay black I love
you and we'll talk next week from New
York what are you waiting for Le
I'm I'm looking for what we wanted to
close with you know what we're closing
with Tom Petty yeah yeah
[Music]
J